thank you for joining us here at 11
o'clock i'm denise valdez and i'm brian
loftis another reason
for that backup more and more visitors
coming to las vegas for halloween
weekend
unfortunately for some kobe 19 has
really pressed pause
on some time-honored traditions now for
families trick-or-treating will prove to
be
fairly risky so some valley parents are
just opting for different ideas to keep
their kids safe
sasha loftus joining us now live tonight
to explain
denise and ryan the parents i spoke with
tonight say safety of course
is their top priority but kids also need
something to look forward to right now
that's why they've come up with a
socially distant option to trick or
treat safely
keeping kids safe while having fun on
halloween
the kids i think are pretty tired of not
doing fun things especially in this
season
valley parents like camellia colemier
are getting creative with their spooky
celebrations
in the age of covid19 we figured we'd
try to be safe as much as possible
at the same time let them be kids she's
teaming up with local businesses
to hold drive through trick-or-treat
events
we have the steel bags the person that's
going to be handing out the candy he's
going to be wearing gloves
and mask of course a-7 health clinical
director
leila yakubuchi says compromises like
this
are crucial to keep everyone healthy
it's still very important to maintain
these precautions because we're
going into the flu season her main
message to continue
avoiding that close contact with others
the more risky
part of that would be that face-to-face
interaction
[Music]
also you know with the candy handing
that
hand to hand would be riskier it doesn't
seem ideal
but kohlmeyer says it's still possible
to stay
positive and experience
everything this eerie holiday has to
offer
let's keep the spirit up as much as
possible because they feed off of our
energy these kids
there are currently two
trick-or-treating drive-through
locations like this
taking place tomorrow if you have a
business though and you would like to
participate
you just have to sign up by 9 a.m
tomorrow and provide about 250 sealed
bags of candy
we have all the information you need to
do that on our website
8newsnow.com for now reporting live
sasha loftis
8 news now